titanfall to a time falls sold over 10
million copies so like I said sequel was
always on the cards however there was
this one sort of thing that people
thought about the first game they're
like it doesn't have a campaign it's the
folks who made call it duty for about a
warfare and a bunch of other great games
and but they did have this thing called
campaign multiplayer which sort of
replaced it and got fed people into the
multiplayer part of the game so I guess
it's kind of this thing now last week or
a couple days ago and one of the guys at
titanfall said that the title to
whatever it's going to be cold it's
going to have a traditional I guess
single-player campaign so I've asked
both you guys or got you both in the
earth kind of talk about whether or not
you think that's a good idea what do you
think it's worthwhile or not I guess
first of all iron where do you sit on
this mmm I really appreciated that
titanfall tried something different I
really like the fact that they
integrated the to the they have the
multiplayer campaign I mean of course
you have problems when you have player
drop off and people trying to finish the
campaign later on but you get around but
my biggest problem with that was just
they didn't commit enough to it not that
it was there there were moments in that
one like there's a mission on the
Odyssey where this is like this derelict
ship we're like there's audio prompts
talking about trying to start the ship
back up but the players were never
fighting in the like engine room bright
or there was one called three towers an
airstrip where they were talking about
following a blood trail but like you
were never following the blood trip yes
like I love the idea they just it they
just need to commit to the idea more so
that players are doing the missions and
then there's like a at least a binary
ending where there actually is the IMC
win or the militia wins cuz yes the way
that campaign ended was there like you
guys want some we guys want some and now
let's go do multi player yeah yeah see
you in the next war and Jesse stern said
one of the shortcomings of the first
game was that we just did not have the
mechanism to tell everyone here here's
who you are here's where you are and
who's around you and we knew all the
answers we just could not deliver on it
there was the kind of smell of a really
new game there or real new University
you were like part of but you like iron
said you kind of never really got into
it that much you think a campaign would
fix that or
do you think they just kind of didn't
execute on the campaign multiplayer idea
well enough well I think the campaign
will inherently allow them to flesh out
the story and provide more context I
mean that's a no-brainer you know I
think it's a worthwhile effort because
it's it's a world that is somewhat
interesting that has you know humans
with abilities and robots to take an
interface with that it's not something
you've seen a lot of games right so just
sort of describe the world around that
and present it in a way that makes it
even more interesting would be a good
move i think but what I'm more
interested in is rather than the online
multiplayer thing where they're talking
about the story so much it's using a
focused you know design campaign to
allow the mechanics to do some
interesting stuff that aren't possible
in multiplayer right we don't want to do
to use to do yeah like build levels
around the the mechanics that you have
your disposal to make some more
interesting gameplay than just this is
multiplayer that's dressed as you know a
story or even just a single player
campaign that is like you against bots
in a similar map or even a similar setup
that you would face like do something
really cool that's different from
multiplayer that's not just telling a
tale one of the things that sort of
comes up whenever companies take on the
whole single-player thing is that
spending time on these like super
focused super like content heavy
development cycles for you know
single-player campaigns might take a
focus away from what otherwise would be
done on multiplayer do you think are
they need to do much more with the
multiplayer of this game because they
kind of seem like they crack them not
really well on the first time around
like how much different how much
different gameplay do you need a head of
a titanfall to it depends I don't know
how I can't speak to how limited they
are on the technical side but I could
think of Tom my head it like there's a
lot that they could do with this game in
terms of when they release map packs
they out the maps worth always
thematically connected and things like
actually having players go seamlessly
from one map to the next map without a
loading screen where you play a series
of maps that feed into each other or
things like doing PVE in the pvp so
there was a map called their level
called there be dragons whether these
giant dragons and when you shot them
they were just kind of like fly off
rather than aggro on characters so I
mean they could add PvE there's I think
that this guy is the limit on the
universe was incredible all of the map
stole
the story and they could add mechanics
if they wanted to and if they had the
technical capabilities to do it we got a
bunch of feedback in on this one
Philippe and your I rajo as puts a
question in here after some distant
disappointments this Jan I don't blame
multiplayer only full price games
anymore so this is totally worth it for
me and when it comes to the campaign in
fact I actually put out a little Twitter
poll I got but one and a half thousand
votes sixty-four percent people said
they were more likely to buy it if it
had a campaign with 34% basically saying
it didn't really matter to them either
way that's kind of the thing right is
that like some people will play a
campaign but we always hear anecdotally
when it comes to games like Call of Duty
some people just don't care so it's
weird it's like you bought this split
where some people will love a campaign
and won't wear the kind of done with
multiplayer only games and then these
other people who are like they just they
think it's a waste of money basically
because I'm never gonna spend time on it
people consider every game for many
different reasons sometimes its brand
you know sometimes they want to get call
of duty because then and their friends
always get the new call of duty and
they're zombies Madden and madden fifa
the same way you know um and but at the
same time if someone just wants a
competitive experience these days there
are so many free to play competitive
shooters hmm that it's like do I need to
drop 60 bucks just for that I feel like
for a lot of people it's got to be a
really compelling game that has
something really different like
titanfall did yeah but now the titanfall
has come out and we've seen that if
they're going to come back again in
charge full price I think they have to
do a campaign your muscle final Rainbow
six siege you've been playing a lot of a
recently that's a game that's
multiplayer only has that the sour at
all it has a situations mode but you
know I have a hard time understanding
how I think single-player campaign sell
games and I think they look pretty they
can make them look pretty they look
right in advertisements yes and I'm not
going to discount their people who
genuinely love single-player games but
if you look at the amount of time that
you're gonna spend in a single player
game on in a shooter not like an RPG
you're gonna spend let's let's just say
like maximum 12 hours in the average
game like 8 to 12 hours okay this is an
infinity ward thing you could probably
you know it would be fair to say it's
already gonna be around five or six
right you can easily spend a hundred
hours that's not exaggeration and some
people spend upwards of 200 hours in
multiplayer so if you're a developer and
you're looking at the budget that it
costs to put in a single player campaign
versus you know the people who are going
to spend 100 or 200 hours in your game
I find it hard to justify multiplayer
shooters wasting such a large portion of
their budget when they can just do twice
the maps or put into some fantastic
destruction technology or you know just
better looking gamer but if you look at
the numbers on his Pole I think that's a
pretty good indication that the majority
of people don't care and so much that
the campaigns are short and that they're
going to get more value if they just
play multiplayer a lot I think it's a
certain type of person that really just
wants to do the multiplayer thing and
then there was like there was you know
thirty-four percent said he didn't care
either way so you could take that as I
enjoy the multiplayer a lot or you could
take the other way and say i don't care
if it's single player like it doesn't
make a difference to me either way and
so yeah it's really strange i wonder if
the fact that as well I did say when I
said Infinity Ward I meant the people
who made those old infinity war games
course is obviously respawn
entertainment for some fellas new thing
and but I wonder if the fact that this
game sold two million copies and it was
an xbox one exclusive and now they're
making a game it's gotta come out on pc
and playstation 4 as well as well as the
xbox one like I wonder if that's the
like if they have a little bit more
leeway you know financially to sort of
make it happen and that maybe this is
there like big play to take care call of
duty right like I bet those guys would
love nothing more than to take over Call
of Duty's like the user market base or
whatever and I guess you're never going
to do it unless you have a campaign
right it's like you got to take that box
for some people and they I mean I'm not
saying they couldn't do a really good
campaign in this world again their map
design for multiplayer we're all fully
fleshed-out worlds like you could walk
around the map and you'd be like well
this is where the ships land here's the
passport office like here's where people
live I mean it was so clear when you
play those maps that somebody actually
sat down and wrote a story and then made
the map as opposed to vice versa so you
know I think it's as they said I think
they knew what the world was and they
may not have had the budget to do the
campaign because again like I thought I
saw an article recently they were saying
as much as 75 percent of their budget my
going to single single player campaign
so it makes sense if you're just trying
to deliver this multiplayer shooter to
compete with call of duty that you just
spend the money on multiplayer and then
if you sell a 10 million copies hey
got the money now let's make a campaign
I should mention as well as about Mexico
point in the twitch at the skating
actually did comment on PC last time
around the time I should yeah that's
true any came out and xbox 360 as well
Oh AJ I judy was an awesome port blue
point productions yeah they did the part
for that they did the part for gravity
rush remastered oh really i know you're
solid HD collection they are one of the
best studios out there that most people
don't know but on top of their master
porters that's excellent a bunch of
people in the chat as well asking i'm in
the multiplayer sort of online shooter
world has changed a little bit a lot
more microtransactions now sort of par
for the course titanfall seem to stay
away from that for the most part they
had a season pass with some maps and
stuff and what do you think about that
do you think they'll dive into that we
spawn seem to be a team were really sort
of they care about what their community
thinks about them when it comes to my
current when it comes to
microtransactions if you make people
care about your game the want to spend
money and i think developers deserve to
make money on the games that they
release I mean the price of a game has
been what's sixty dollars for ya lon
decade now and I think a lot of the
reasons why you're seeing crazy stuff
like premium and you know battlefront
launching with for signature maps / mode
I think their budgets are getting cut
down by the fact that they're still
selling games for sixty dollars and so I
think at this point developers are
either gonna have to raise the price of
games do things like premium or do micro
transactions it doesn't seem like just
that what I gather from talking to
developers it just doesn't seem like the
sixty dollar game is going to cover
their costs anymore yeah so to me micro
transactions are the lesser evil if
they're done right if they're not
cutting out contents and making you feel
like you're not getting a good deal if
they're making you love the game and
then they're giving you things that you
want to buy because you love the game
just as long as they're not you know
yeah taking away some of the the
fairness in it like I member the burn
cards they add in the first game if you
could suddenly like just acquire a bunch
of those FIFA style yeah I guess we'll
find out it depends most of the lot of
games have just gone vanity with ya with
it I'm interesting over watch out like
the debate is at this morning in fact is
going to be a stream on right after this
live show which are K is going to be
playing the game they've got a bunch of
new skins and whatnot I'm sure they're
going to start selling those bad boys do
there's egregious breach
that though like a you know you
battlefront they sold the DL 44 blasters
Han Solo's blaster for ten dollars extra
and dollars and it was [ __ ] it was
the highest level unlock in the game and
ended up being the Opie pistol that
everybody hated oh really so like that
was just totally egregious that was just
there yeah Leah like just throw grenade
and close the door kind of blast DLC
moves so I get why people are
apprehensive when you know yeah like
your transactions get kicked around ya
can't trust them apart from that though
last thoughts on this excited for time
fall to tootin fall yeah Respawn
Entertainment is one of the few
developers that I've spoken with in
previews right where a lot of developers
give you their BS marketing push and you
don't believe them you learn not to
believe them these guys I thought that
they were being me and then they
delivered this like five or six v6
combat that I thought you couldn't do
with mex and they had great mechanics
like ejecting just to give you more time
to play the game a lot of the things
that I thought they were being me on I
was totally wrong like they were
absolutely right and they knew what they
were doing so I'm excited to be proven
wrong if I'm doubtful of this game again
if if that happens again I will be very
excited yeah that'd be awesome Peter why
by yourself I'm very much excited
titanfall was one of the best shooters
for me in probably a decade or more I
love the new things they did and I can't
wait to see what else to have with their
sleeve I really want there to be new
Titans that do some ridiculous [ __ ] and
I'll be really happy it was a game that
sort of I guess it was one of the early
games that came out on that next
generation of consoles the current gen
now it felt like it was like eighty
percent of the way of being something
something super super special oh yeah
yeah because it was really special but
it was like never like that long sucker
punches never came I think it's and I
hate to say the campaign is the most
important thing because I don't think it
is but when you really want to identify
with a world like you got a struggle you
gotta succeed you have to let go through
you know what it means to be a person in
that world not just have someone in your
ear telling you hey I just want to
convince you that you're really here and
that you're a part of this [ __ ] like you
have to live and breathe it and do it
and so yeah that that should be really
cool they can pull that off Kobe could
go either way you never know like some
games you play a lot of multiplayer some
games you've just played a campaign like
i like to call of duty and i won't even
ever played a multi bear another good
kill zone and i won't even played single
page guess we'll see where this one
lands let us know what you think if
you're excited about
the new titanfall game whatever it's
going to be called please call it to
Nepal let us know in the comments below